ông bị bắt đầu nói là nãy giờ mic không
mở hồi nãy giờ mình ngồi độc thoại và
anh
có
anh gọi mấy ông sẽ phải bù phải ngồi
nghe tôi Bố tôi sẽ ngồi nó lại tôi đâu
Vì sao rồi Các bạn ai cả chưởng lại cho
mình độc thoại tôi tôi tâm sự hết rồi à
phải nói sớm chứ còn còn bắt X X on on 7
phút rồi mày ông Thế chứng tỏ không có
tâm đúng không 7 phút liền
ừ ừ
Ừ Ok nó xin theo độc lại
chả không cắt được đi đâu Ờ
thôi xin phép tâm sự lại về nó gọi là
tuổi học trò Nhưng mà thực tế là là tôi
không không nói về cụ thể là tôi đã học
hành như nào mà tôi nói cụ thể luôn là
hồi lớp 12 của tôi lúc mà kiểu cuối năm
đó mà tôi được đi chụp kỷ yếu
thì Trường tôi tổ chức chụp kỷ yếu lại
trùng vào ngày mà trường FPT tổ chức thi
để lấy học bổng nghe thành a Hồi đấy ở
tôi phải đứng giữa sự lựa chọn là kiểu
tương lai mình sẽ sáng sủa đi về đâu
hiểu lấy vợ sinh cho Vân nói chung và
tươi sáng nếu mà nếu do sử ra cầu kiếm
hợp đồng hồ lấy tôi nghĩ hay đi chụp kỷ
yếu và tôi chọn là tôi đi thi để bấm vào
đi hồi đấy á học phí ở FPT đã là bốn
triệu rưỡi hả 31 tháng cả đất thì cuối
cùng thì tôi thi nhưng mà không được học
bổng 50 phần trăm đây là tôi vẫn quyết
định không học ở FPT vì nó khá chi phí
khá đắt mà
ờ thì ờ nhưng mà tôi lỡ mất một một lần
chụp kiểu
sau đó thì khi mà
lĩnh vực nào tôi không Tôi bị trượt đại
học vẫn cảm thấy may mắn đến bây giờ tôi
vẫn thấy may mắn khi tôi trượt 2 trường
mà tôi đăng ký vào
Ừ bia trường lấy rất rất xa nhà tôi kết
hợp việc hồi đấy ở đường đường sửa rất
nhiều Nói chung là tôi cảm thấy là tôi
tôi kiểu ngay từ hôm đi đăng ký nhập thủ
tục nhập học ở đấy tôi cảm thấy đó Chiều
nay giống như kiểu chứ bỏ mình đi đường
thì đường đang sửa xong rồi hôm đấy
giông bão giông bão cực đấy các thứ
à
Xong rồi nói chung là tôi vào với trường
này là một xưởng may mắn
Lúc mà tôi vào thì kệ nó vẫn còn thấy
khá tốt và tâm huyết và cậu mình
anh nói chung là mọi thứ đều gọi là cũng
khá suôn sẻ
rồi nhưng mà nó có nhược điểm đó là
trường của tôi thời gian nó không hề nổi
nhanh hay ra là và nó khá là bé hồi mà
tôi học
anh alo
em vẫn chưa nói gì à ông tôi thấy Mic
lên rồi mà không đòi quà ông đừng có
chém thôi nha
ờ ờ ờ ờ
5 ở tòa nhà thế thôi Không nửa thôi nhá
nửa thôi đấy bà sinh lượng sinh viên ít
nó không có cả khuôn viên trường nó
không có cả nơi mà sinh viên tụ tập với
nhau các số thứ không có thư viện về gì
cả đấy và
thôi khóa biểu của bọn tôi cũng sẽ chỉ
là một ngày một buổi 4 tiếng và một tuần
5 buổi thôi nghĩa thời gian ở trên
trường với nhau rất là ít cái này ra là
ở và trường thôi trường nghề họ chỉ 35
Nhưng thực tế là năm nhất thì học đại
cương này 52 học lập trình web mà và năm
53 đi học lập trình lập trình áp cụ thể
Android Nhưng thực tế là là 52 Bọn tôi
học Làm lập trình web xong bỏ tôi đã
kiểu đi làm rồi cũng gần như không đi
học mấy nữa anh ra à cả thời gian Bọn
tôi ở với nhau rất ít
Vì thế nên là đại học của tôi cũng không
có kiểu luôn không có chục triệu đi cả
không đoàn kết thì bây giờ tôi anh chả
liên lạc với bạn đại học à
anh em thấy là kiểu tối cuộc cuộc đời
thôi hai lần gặp hai lần này chụp kiểu
đi không có cả hai thế thôi vừa nãy rồi
Đang định nghĩa là có khi ở biết đâu
Mình làm một cái buổi cần chụp kiểu cho
các bạn ở ở Hà Nội cũng được cái thuốc
hóa anh anh em là một cái Chụp kiểu mà
tôi non mà theo tôi cũng sẽ ở hòa với
mấy ông nhận mình làm sinh viên được nó
đỡ tủi thân
à à
a packet của tôi là là DK Z không phải
BK cát cái tk áp ạ
ừ ừ
Ừ thì cuộc đời tôi nói sông À gần như là
là phải phải và miễn cưỡng và phải
trưởng thành sớm như thế nghĩa Lúc mà
tôi 52 tôi đi làm thì các bạn rồi còn
đang thực vật mới một lại cương xong rồi
Lúc mà tôi lên làm thầy
cho mấy bạn tôi vẫn đang chậm Mấy cái
môn ở trên trường này tôi đi làm rồi tôi
phải trưởng thành sớm hơn các bạn thôi
tôi gọi qua trạm sớm hơn như nó nhược
điểm là mình không có những cái tuổi thơ
thiếu thốn lại dùng từ thiên vốn sẽ
không được như các bạn là kiểu dạng mà
học nội trú vui cùng nhau buồn thiếu
thúc nhau với Vân bởi nhà tôi cũng ở Hà
Nội cũng không cần phải học nội trú gì
cả không có tuổi sinh viên thì đây à
em cũng chưa đi À thỉnh nguyện hai mấy
cái kiểu mấy câu lạc bộ bây giờ nhà kẹo
Tôi thấy à hiểu tôi cũng khá mất mày này
những cái khoảnh khắc sinh viên đấy
ừ ừ
Ừ anh ấy giờ tôi có người yêu mày ông
không còn không
sao tôi hơn cái đấy nhưng mà nhưng mà
nói chung là tôi thấy cuộc đời tôi nó Nó
là một cái sự kiểu mình phải chuyển hàng
sớm trải nghiệm sớm khác nhiều cũng thấy
em thấy mình thiếu sót nhiều cái à
khi mở Tiện đây xác là tôi tâm sự về cái
vụ
vụ này nhưng mà không phải về cá nhân
tôi mà tôi định nói chung nói chung về
hiểu rằng là là
kiểu lời khuyên mày ông theo góc nhìn
của tôi mấy ngày hôm nay tôi nghĩ nhé
Ngày hôm nay thật ra có bạn bà tại sao
mấy hôm nay em không thấy anh tâm sự gì
cả Không phải vì tôi không muốn không Có
gì tâm sự mà tôi thực ra tôi nghĩ khá
nhiều
em có cả nhiều cái nó hơi tiêu cực một
tí không không muốn chia sẻ với ông
À hôm nay ổn định hơn rồi thì sẽ kiểu
nói được
hi hi
à à Thực sự như tôi đã từng nói với ông
à là chúng ta phải phải biết được là
mình nên tìm một con người như thế nào
để mà để mật khẩu
Ừ thứ nhất là mình phải đạt ta ví dụ là
sự là
người yêu lý tưởng của mình là gì không
ạ
chị lấy sau đó thì mình thấy bản thân
mình ở xứng đáng với những cái người đấy
Hay chưa và kiểu người ví dụ kiểu người
con gái ấy thì sẽ đang ngồi con gà nhé
thì thì thì sẽ nên gặp ở có thể gặp ở
đâu và họ sẽ làm gì cả nhận vân
cho ví dụ ví dụ như là tôi
em đứng yên à đương nhiên là cái tầm
tuổi là 25 của tôi thì có thể có thể lấy
vợ rồi
Em có nhưng mà
ở tầm tuổi của các bạn nhỏ hơn chẳng hạn
thiếu thể là vẫn chỉ yêu ơi chứa xác
định là lấy hay gì đó thì Theo tôi nghĩ
tôi đang nghĩ nhá giống như nhà làm như
là mình trải nghiệm nhiều hơn là cậu
thực sự là kiểu đi đến đi đến hôn nhân
hay gì đó thì cái việc trải nghiệm với
không Tôi nghĩa không nên chị trải
nghiệm thuộc dạng nào vui mà nên nên là
kiểu ở
cho nên là kiểu dạng là cả hai người có
thể cậu giúp nhau tiến bộ hơn
A và đương nhiên ở về sau sau này không
ai biết được sẽ cười cái gì đó rồi đấy
Không ai chắc chắn một điều gì cả nhưng
ý rồi Đây là mình tìm tìm người kia thì
nên như thế nào không phải ông nên cô
đơn quá Đâu có nên vụ và một người tôi
không Tôi không khuyên thế
à mà là mà là mình mình hướng đến cái
người như thế nào ví ví dụ ví dụ giống
như ở trong trường hợp của tôi em ạ tôi
là dân công nghệ đúng không ạ gì
số 1 là ông ông theo người trong ngành
nhưng mà cả hai cùng giúp đỡ cho nhau
trong ngày nhưng mà thực về cá nhân tôi
thì tôi nghĩa là chúng ta bị thú với Chả
giấu mà sự nghĩa là nó chỉ là giải thích
người ngoài nhàng hơn và người trong
hàng không ạ Người ngoài ngành thì nên
làm như thế nào giả sử hôm qua Hôm qua
hơi chẳng ạ tôi đi cà phê một bạn bạn
đấy ngồi tư vấn nó tôi về bảo hiểm chẳng
hạn thế
rồi Tôi cảm thấy à Thế à tôi
Ừ từ gà Tôi không biết tôi Tôi không
biết được mấy con điểm nào như hồi trước
tôi khá kỳ thị về một số vụ bảo hiểm về
tôi cảm thấy à Cứ ngồi nghĩ nó nhiều hơi
bị tiêu cái đầu cứ nghĩ là mình sẽ không
vấn đề gì đấy Con Vân em tôi không không
nghĩ về cái vụ bảo hiểm
a nhớ bạn ấy có nói đâu hả rất hay nếu
vì sao ông bị sao Thì sao hay và Vần
kiểu gì cũng phải lo vụ đấy thì tôi vẫn
không muốn nghĩ về vụ đấy thực sự là đến
đứng đều tội không có nghĩ một đấy đi em
lúc đấy tôi có suy nghĩ đơn giản là là
kiếm người để ủng hộ mình vụ đấy mình sẽ
chỉ làm những cái thứ minh giỏi dỗ ra
xưởng mình giỏi công nghệ thì rõ kiếm
tiền em ạ Còn người yêu mình sẽ là
thế mà lo mày ngủ đây Ừ mua lại hiểm thì
chuẩn ra nó sẽ ra cái đấy mình bớt nghĩ
ở một đấy mình Nó là một cái sự bảo đảm
cho mình mà đúng không ạ nhưng mà để
tính toán thì mấy cái tôi đang nói là
bảo hiểm chuyển một cái một cái thôi thì
tôi ở với cái việc tính toán
chi tiêu Hải là kiểu
xe cẩn thận học với cái vụ vụ đấy ạ thì
cá ở Tôi không nghĩ vụ này nhiều đâu thì
tôi nghĩ à chị đấy Có Một Người
anh lo cho mình nghĩ Liệu mình về cái
đấy cũng hay tôi nghĩ thế
khi nghe tôi nghĩ thế đâu nhá Không biết
mày không có điểm nào thế nhiều người
thì quan điểm là chỉ là mình phải lo
được cho bản thân mình trước khi kiếm
người yêu con tôi thì nghĩ ra là bản
thân một người không hoàn hảo để có thể
mà
à mà kiểu có thể mà có là em làm hết tất
cả những cái vụ đấy mình nên làm những
thứ mình giỏi và đương nhiên là mấy thì
kiếm người khác giỏi thêm mạc kia để mà
cả hai cùng hỗ trợ nhau thế tôi tôi thì
ở quan điểm như thế đó là sự bù trừ nhau
ấy chứ nếu mà ông cố giỏi hết một mảnh
với nhưng không thể ngờ kiểu gì ông sẽ
bị thâm tâm nhiều cái nữa không tập
trung vào mạng của ông ông hiểu lý do gì
sẽ bao gồm trả lời có họ nhá tâm sự cho
thế thôi
ờ ờ
sống Không anh à
mà Trừ lúc ngủ trong lúc nào sử dụng
được điện tử thật ra là không
thực tế nhá Tôi
Ừ tôi Tuy ở Tôi rất thích và tôi rất là
kiểu khi mà nhìn cái gì đó tôi lương xưa
nghĩa thế hàng xảy ra có thể giải quyết
bằng bài toán công nghệ sẽ tiện hơn nó
sẽ chở tối ưu hơn con Văn Lợi giữa tôi
thương ai trên những cái ứng dụng đều
khác Chẳng hạn nhưng tôi khi mà đi Đi ra
ngoài ví dụ cuối tuần này tôi sẽ gần như
là
trừ khi mà kiểu có lỗi của bất khi đó
giống như một đống tin nhắn này chắc
chắn là đang có bất gì đó thì tôi sẽ
ngồi làm còn thứ bảy chủ nhật là cần nhở
tôi
à Cậu cần nhớ cho mình cái sự nghỉ ngơi
gì đó cũng ngờ khi mà đi đi chơi Tôi rất
ít lôi điện thoại ra
ở thời sự như ý rẫy khi nói điện thoại
ra nhưng người khác thì tôi biết nhau
nhưng đấy 1 sự tôi cảm thấy nó không có
tôn trọng
mọi người xung quanh lắm Bởi vì bây giờ
giả sử ông đi hẹn hò nhau đi Thôi anh
cầm điện thoại nó không hay lắm nhưng
tôi đã không Hạn chế sử dụng đây cũng mẹ
các hơi thở
anh nói chung là tôi cũng là cha hướng
ngoại nhưng tôi thích kiểu ra ngoài ra
tiếp các thứ nữa
Em thích ra ngoài giao tiếp Nhưng mà
thực tế là để mà đi chơi nhiều rồi đó là
cũng không thích đâu Ví dụ ở cá nhân mà
bây giờ tìm nghỉ rồi chứ không phải là
nhiều dẫn mình đi chơi cả ngày không
phải như thế mà tôi muốn hiểu là một
người của
ngồi mình mình ngồi làm việc và họ cũng
làm việc của họ tôi chỉ muốn có người
rồi ở bên cậu mình gần như mình ngồi làm
việc cùng với họ thấy vui rồi Kiểu như
thế
học HTML CSS và Hoặc ra Speed thì có
chậm quá không 53 đường bắt đầu học
chuyên ngành mà Đấy là tôi nghĩa là là
nó bình thường thôi không có gì là chậm
cả nhờ bạn không theo ngày này còn bây
giờ mới bắt đầu học
học lập trình có sao đâu
ngôn ngữ ạ Ở giống như tôi hiện tại này
Bây giờ tôi đang chuyên pp thôi có
chuyên ngôn ngữ khác đâu Đương nhiên
biết thêm bên g-suite để mà làm cả
fulltech nhưng mà thực tế là tôi chuyên
p hơn cái việc chuyên ngôn ngữ Không sao
cả bởi vì Nếu giả sử vì sau ngôn ngữ đấy
nó đúng là nó không còn được sử dụng nữa
thì việc nhảy sang ngôn ngữ khác nó vẫn
nó vẫn được bởi vì ngôn ngữ mày Ngôn ngữ
này thì các bạn nó không khác nhau lắm
vì nó không khác nhau lắm đấy à việc ở
ông thích nhảy sang ngôn nữa nào cũng
được nhưng là Cái quan trọng là ông cần
hiểu bản chất bạn của của lập trình đã
ở đâu mà sao thì tôi chuyên bác em rồi
đúng không Nhưng mà Bởi vì ở công ty rồi
cần phải làm cả ăn để màn hiển thị ra
kết quả mình đã làm nữa suýt cao hơn cụ
thể là dùng thêm thuốc dress with để mà
theo nó thối yêu bởi vì à Nếu mà dùng pp
được rồi thì thị ra thì trang web rất là
lâu ấy thì phải dùng Facebook ra Swift
để mà kiểu hình chị lên cho mày cái
tương tác đó Thử thứ thì nó không cần là
nó lạy cha này bạn Vân thì thì học ra
chút ít thôi nó biết thực ra là nọ nó
đương nhiên là để học chuyên sâu nó thì
nó cũng lằng nhằng nhưng mà nhưng mà học
mod Speed để cơ bản được hiển thị lên
thì lại quá đơn giản
giờ tôi vẫn chưa chuyên về xem Quốc lắp
chưa biết về view lắm về chưa tụ tự làm
một cái gì đó Từ đầu nhưng mà vào công
ty kiểu dạng làm anh em đã chốt rồi mình
chỉ việc xem và Minh hiểu qua được hiểu
Đọc cốt hiểu thôi mình sẽ copy rồi mà ví
dụ mình làm tình năng hiển thị thì mình
sẽ bắt chước cái trang nào để mà gần giờ
mình sẽ bắt chước xanh đấy để làm với
tính năng nhưng nó rất là nhanh giờ dễ
mà không Không có gì cả để mà học từ đầu
mất thêm thời gian nhưng mà để mà đi
copy Cốt và sửa code thì không nghĩa là
anh em lên cái tầm Junior thì điều gì sẽ
làm thì thôi
giờ mình sẽ bắt đầu chuyên mục hôm nay
là tôi sẽ chấm tất cả các nhóm hôm nay
chấm mát tuần trước đã không chấm rồi Ờ
em ạ thì tuần tuần này mình sẽ chấm qua
tất cả các nhóm để mà
bí mật khẩu mình tôi sẽ đánh giá qua một
nửa các ngọn luôn tiến trình đến đâu và
mấy ông nhớ là để làm không nhỉ Thế nay
là cái này Hôm nào nghỉ mở lại xem cách
anh đem hay là hôm nay á
Anh là gì
top 10 đây là đủ no hôm nay hôm nay luôn
ở đây la hôm nay
số 16 tháng 7 review tất cả các tính
năng các nhóm đã làm và 31 tháng 7 sẽ có
một buổi bảo vệ thường
đóng ngoặc à
cho nên là xem tiến độ từng nhóm như thế
nào những nhóm và đương nhiên là có
những nhóm thì gần đây cũng nói cho các
bạn cũng bận rộn mà nên là rất nhiều
nhóm mở cửa của đấy Ở vẫn đang chậm tiến
độ hơn son nhóm khác thì tôi sẽ xem qua
một lần sau
anh em yêu trước hết thì xem từng nhóm
ấy nhỉ
cập nhật Cái gì cả
ở nhóm này
Em thích đâu rồi
Ừ ok nhầm tiếp theo nhóm A này
nhóm này thì như hôm trước là một kiểm
tra rồi
Tình Cha
I Were tô comment
khi mua xem thử các tính năng xem à
thì nó sẽ kiểu mở nhanh hơn
Anh ấy thấy cảnh sát vai tá trả kiểu là
amin chưa gì cả này sao Mình chưa gì càn
chưa
a a word our Economy
Nếu bạn chưa có gì cả
anh em thấy ông bị chậm chế độ báo rồi
ờ ờ
này thì vậy không
Ừ hi vọng không có lỗi gì cả
à à
hộ vai đơ
các bạn làm tính năng xóa à
cho nên hạn chế không cần tính năng xóa
hay là hay là nói chung chẳng cầm lên
tính năng xóa
tính năng thêm sữa xóa rồi Gần như là
cần Như là kiểu ở
một mình à
cho nó xóa thì cả mình làm gì nó khác
à à bạn đấy làm là admin là ăn wrinkle
tất cả bên emminh ga nên có một thư mục
một thư mục lá Min sau đó thì mình sẽ có
forwarder controller thì nó hợp lý hơn
hai cẩu như này Ừ ông hiểu gì đâu thì nó
sẽ ổn hơn
bí thư mục admin Dương giá
cho em coi đi này
a cho bạn này cũng làm tương đối rồi
cho Android this cũng được cho có vẻ ổn
Đấy mua đồ này
Các bạn ơi
Không không không đoạn này nên là sale
này nó hợp lý hơn
như này ở đây à
a seller chính cái mua đồ này trước
không nên dùng dp như thế nhưng mà đi
bên như thế thì nó không phải là đây là
quần đâu
hiểu đoạn nào
thì tại sao bạn này có chấm phẩy đấy lại
bằng đấy nhỉ
Có ai đi vô select ID wana bé
anh không hiểu đàn này bạn để làm gì lắm
chú ý
I enjoy sắt và cho Việt Nam này ok
sắt
em không có tôi không hiểu đoạn này lắm
ngày thì cũng không lên này bởi vì có
mày xong đây Alice this danh sách giờ
Nghe danh sách ID
Có ai đi ở đây nếu mà nó xuống nhiều
đúng không nó xuống nhiều thì ông sẽ
chạy gần đây câu truy vấn để mà lấy ra
cái này không nên mà mình sẽ dùng vít ở
đây là làm bài làm đoạn này nó hơi bị ạ
à mà nó sẽ bị nặng n câu truy vấn kiểu
có bao nhiêu mang bao nhiêu
có bao nhiêu u dâu sẽ lập bấy nhiêu lần
để lấy cô Vân này không nên nó lắm
3000 đi làm kiểu ngay mày kết quả cũng
chả ra thôi nhưng mà làm đoạn này thôi
bạn có phốt như này lấy mỗi lên nữa trả
lại nó sẽ là trả về toàn bộ kovan như là
bạn lấy mỗi nêm trở lại nó bị
Ừ nó kiểu ngày nó hơi bị sai Này bạn này
nhìn trông vệ cốt được nhưng mà nhưng mà
đang
Em đang làm gì cho nó chạy được chứ
không có tối gì cả
mấy ông hệ tham khảo tất cả nhỏ mông nhé
Đấy đấy do mục đích của buổi hôm nay mày
không
Angela không có gì
Ê mày có mua đồ mà có Factory này
Ừ nhưng mà thiếu nhiều quá
ô tô G2 giá thử trả thù bỏ qua có gì
chấm được ờ
a tiếp năm sáu này
Ừ chị Vân tạm Vân như thế này à
có thôi chứ tôi thế cũng chẳng áp dụng
gì đây cả
Ừ ừ cũng được mà thấy là áo cũng được
Việt namđinh hôm nào
từ hôm nay Linh
ở Nam Định nhảy Master còn hôm lại nhảy
Lan đi
Anh chưa hiểu này lắm Thôi kệ vậy Ờ
anh Hải Âu rồi Tại sao cần 2-hour đây
nhỉ
các clipart
tạm Tok em cái này cái này là tôi chưa
dậy mấy ông này cái này là gần trưa cái
này cũng là một kiểu áo nó xã An toàn
cái này nó là xinh cho Ken ra theo kiểu
nào giống như là Coffee mỗi người sẽ có
một cái to kèm riêng giống kiểu tóc em
Facebook nó kêu nó sẽ hiểu và đại diện
cho tài khoản ông và ông sẽ đăng nhập
thông qua Token này và cái này phù hợp
là giống dùng cái tóc đen Facebook ở
điểm mà Tại sao ông có thể làm kiểu nằm
áp ông thể dùng cho cái này đăng nhập
vào mẹ ơi Bởi vì a bản chất áp nó sẽ
không có xin nghỉ cả nó khác với kiểu
web và kết hợp việc là vì tóc em nên
thành ra nó sẽ không hết hạn giống như
kiểu xinh xinh xinh là ông ông đôi khi
ông đóng máy hay gì đó thì nó sẽ kết
thúc phiên season ông ạ nhưng mà còn còn
Token này nó là công ty thì nó sẽ cho
ông chỉ cần ông truyền lại cái tao quen
đấy ông sẽ đăng nhập Ừ
hi Ông thấy mày cài App ứng dụng kiểu nó
nào giống như Facebook Ông thấy vẫn còn
gì thì đăng nhập cái ngoài có mỗi lần nó
cũng ông tắt Facebook đi bao giờ phải
đăng nhập lại không Không nên như thế
không ạ Chị sẽ dùng qua tôi quen và nó
bảo mật khá tốt
Ừ nhưng mà đương nhiên à nếu mà ông để
lộ ra hay gì đó thì không để lộ ra thì
mất thôi
mà vẫn đăng nhập bản chất là bởi vì A
cái avatar này tùy thật chịu tất cả ngày
đi rồi nhưng mà nó chờ vui lại cái này
ra là nó ghi log nó khác nhá ông Tạm nào
thay nhé nên là hình ra là xinh vẫn còn
thôi Thế ông già sống với vợ ông không
tắt kèo mở lại thì có thể đôi khi sinh
nó mất rồi đấy mẹ em ạ
Ừ lát ngày để làm gì đấy blog ghi tên
tuổi ông này cũng bị giống ông kia là
thay vì quýt để mà lấy ra cái sắp check
các theo hướng này ông chơi trò là ông
Ừ ông chạy vòng lặp có bao nhiêu thằng
này thì ông chạy bấy nhiêu ngay tôi chả
chưa Hướng dẫn mình không phải vụ này
nghỉ thì tao hướng dẫn cho mấy ông cách
để mà lấy Chị lấy mấy ông chỉ một lời là
mỗi nêm thôi đúng không này nó sẽ như
này
post Tôi muốn lấy tô Company name ID hẳn
tôi một lời Company name mình hạn đúng
không Để tôi làm nhanh người ông nha
đồng lọc không không có 1
Ừ
tôi sẽ nhảy vào bên A
đã test catalogues
Anh Đài Giả sử tôi có mày đang poster
Spider đúng không
có sửa đây là post I
I was in ngon thật sự là tôi cứ
a z đời mà tôi sẽ Remix 10 đi
lấy ra 10 rằng chúng tôi tên hàng post
đúng chức
ngày đó Ngoại Ô
ủng
hộ web mua rồi này test mà
chị sẽ lấy ra 10 hàng đóng ngoặc bảo lỗi
đấy bởi vì ở đây đấy
anh nghe sao được không không báo lỗi
lại sẽ có 10 hàng như này nhưng mà chờ
xử Tôi muốn lấy Coffee nêm để lại không
ạ Mấy ông đã dùng súng các thử thứ có
thể có thể là dùng cho ở đây được Nhưng
mà thường mà tôi như tôi đang bảo anh sẽ
nên dùng DC ship nó tốt nhất của thằng
laser thì mình sẽ là
anh đi sẽ có mình tặng một cái ở đây tạo
một recently và Company rồi mình sẽ quýt
này quýt như thế này Company thôi
anh như này là là đã xong rồi mình đã
thế là có thêm thằng with như này và
mình đã có thể lấy nên theo kiểu là theo
kiểu là kiểu mình sẽ mình mình có thể
lấy ví dụ nha mình sẽ khói cả Đây này ra
sự đây posts ở đây là số nhiều nhé
chả phê mỗi
boss cho đến Company này cho anh lên như
thế này
là xong rồi như thế này nhưng mà nhưng
mà ở đây nó sẽ bị nhược điểm khi mấy ông
thấy là giả sử ở tôi mùa đã sử em không
thích kiểu cho đến đêm cả nhà em muốn
lấy là kiểu khamenei gạch sửa lên như
này thì sao đúng ạ
Ừ thì nó sẽ có 2 cách ở đây một là ông
sẽ tạo giống như bạn vừa nãy tạo đó là
ông có thể tạo kiểu dạng là ông sẽ tạo
một cái là Company name ở đây thôi
à à
em
ở như này sợ ông sẽ bản chất là ông Huy
tên goroth
Company I
khi chọn lên nha à
Ừ thì nó vẫn như nhau đúng ạ xong rồi Có
bạn bảo là em không muốn làm như này em
muốn à là thậm chí là em muốn mà em đây
rồi đợi ẩn à rito Mỗi post thôi nhá Em
muốn là ờ nhất là em không muốn thì ở
công ty ở đây nó có quá nhiều thông tin
đấy thì em buồn là Company name nó sẽ tự
động thêm luôn ở trong giống như này nó
nó vẫn lá gọi ra như này nhưng mà nó ở
ngay bên trọng chứ không phải là nó nó
phải tạo thêm một em những thằng đối
tượng Company nữa thì cái đoạn này nó
lại lằng nhằng hơn một tí thì giống như
vừa nãy có bạn đang làm nó là ghét để
lấy thông tin ra không ạ sau đó mình sẽ
dùng mát này nói chuyện này không ạ Mình
sẽ kiểu với từng Hằng thì mình sẽ thì
mình sẽ lấy đúng rồi mình sẽ cậu company
anh lên ngay sẽ bằng
x tại Company
lại lên như này
Ê pete ơn về ích sản
ông xem nhé thì đây trông thấy có
Company name Nó sẽ được chèn thêm đoạn
này đúng chứ và ông sẽ có thể là ông thể
là ông bỏ cái cái Company này đi cũng
được sau khi lấy xong rồi Này ông sẽ bỏ
đi nhưng nọ tôi nhớ là nó là mic không
phải vcloud nữa nó là xóa xóa đi hoặc
ông gọi nhà nghỉ
ờ ờ
đoạn này nó sẽ là kiểu cho ăn xét không
biết anh sẽ được không à
anh không không không biết được không
nha chửi nha à
máy đánh bài có bạn sẽ được Bà xóa xóa
Company đi Nếu thấy tôi thêm vào một cái
số tôi xóa đi không ạ Ok chưa
để hạn chế dùng roi Vì thực tế là ông
ông Khi mà ông thùng bia chẳng chip này
nó có rất nhiều điểm mạnh không và ông
áp dụng để trong rất nhiều cái cơ sở
liệu khác thậm chí ở cái này còn áp dụng
được cả trong ông về xong xử lý là có
thể 33 cơ sở liệu và sự là FBI lại sang
máy quen để xóa Forest Thằng Hải Vân vẫn
có thể chơi quýt như này được lấy thông
tin con Và thậm chí nhảy sang ở nấu ếch
cái nào được vào mông cô đi về được ông
vẫn thể nhảy sang mấy ông tin con khi mà
không dùng cho thì bản chất nó không thể
được vì cùng cơ sở dữ liệu thì ông ấy để
dành cho được Và thậm chí esquire làm
xong nhảy sang nói were dùng cho được
đúng ạ bây rõ ràng nó hết quen làm gì có
coi đúng ạ Đấy thì khi mong dùng vít như
thế này bản chân mà tại sao tự nhiên nó
mất ko nghĩ ra cái quýt Nếu không phải
tự thắc mắc này như thế Tại sao nó nó
sinh ra cái roi là tiệm nó nhanh ở trong
mẹ trong Mà tại sao nó lại sinh ra cái
Quýt làm gì nữa Tại sao lại sinh aricent
này nó có lý do nó cả để mà về sau giả
sử Giả sử Nga là thằng Company này của
ông này nó lại là ở bên ta quét chán thế
đi sẽ có connexion này topic connections
như này
là bên quét em ạ Như này cơ
Ông vẫn sẽ lấy vô tư kể with như này như
bình thường luôn bởi vì sao Bởi vì À cái
câu truy vấn toàn bộ bài đăng là một câu
truy vấn riêng câu truy vấn lấy Company
là một câu truy vấn riêng câu truy vấn
này Company nó luôn Where in kẻ ID toàn
bộ ID
nằm trong danh sách post code này chứ
không phải là hạ là gộp câu truy vấn nên
thành ra là hai câu truy vấn là một câu
chuyện vẫn ở bên em Mai của em à một câu
chỉ cần lướt web nó vẫn chạy bình thường
ơi
khi uống nghiệp thế mạnh của wii chưa
của relationship nó chưa đấy bà Thậm chí
cái này có thể nhảy sang cả molibe lặng
thế
anh Tăng thân Eriol uống nó kết nối ở
cảm ứng coolpad thì cái này vẫn được
không sao cả
đương nhiên là nó không tối ưu về cái
truy vấn bởi vì như tôi nói thì em quen
nó truy vấn về do là nhanh hơn
cho nó nhanh hơn nên là về sau nếu mấy
ông muốn tối ưu thì đúng là phải dùng
roi hoặc lợn phí ở trong nhiều lốp và
dùng nhiều cái nữa nhưng mà còn về cơ
bản Bây giờ tôi đang dạy mấy ông thì tôi
đang hướng cho mấy ông là là kiểu dùng
mấy cái nó mạng đấy chứ không phải là
mấy ông chơi cho kiểu là út trai giống
như hồi trước Nếu mà ông Cùng do như hồi
trước mà thằng là nó vẫn là cô chai bởi
vì nó không tận dụng của recently không
tận dụng của Eric quần đấy nó không khởi
tạo đối tượng kiểu như thế á nhon
hot girl sử ship của em không dùng được
with ấy chứ
Em
có vào nhóm nào mông kêu không dùng
thấy tiếng trả với trai nó không khác gì
nhà đâu chẳng qua tụi tao kéo chạy tới
dùng Elise rồi không khác gì đâu
Tối nay ngồi sửa cốt tôi ngay từ lúc đầu
tôi dậy mấy ông Chuẩn rồi Chuẩn noi ông
tự ông tự khiến mình khó khó hơn đấy chứ
năm sáu à anh sẽ gửi cho em sau nhé
2862 hiện tại đây đúng không có gì đâu
mà không dùng được lên giết đến bây giờ
nè
anh không được mà
Ừ ông đấy Sắp chắc nêm đúng không có gì
đâu mà không được alo
sắp cách nêm
à à Ông muốn lấy nó ra nào thì giảm mạnh
tên Môn Đúng không
thứ ngày
thích kiểu lấy một ID và lấy mỗi lên
ngay thôi
hạn chế lấy nhiều đấy Nhớ anh
ghét như hai đúng không Rồi mát ngay
đúng không
Sắp chắc nêm thế này ông sẽ có
là
mấy giờ cho đến sắp chết rồi đây
em
bé xong mà
Anh chưa hiểu ông thấy đoạn này như nào
đấy như này thôi phát sóng được đúng nhỉ
Đấy thử nhé để tôi thử luôn nhé
có một thằng có nhiều đúng không
có một thằng có nhiều ạ
a Company ra nha tôi sẽ chạy thử test
thử cho ông luôn nhé Tôi sẽ à
đây tôi có quy
à à bosna
có nhiều bài đăng mà nó ngon đấy
em thật sự remix một thôi này
trình
a
public
thì nó sẽ cậu ghi tên goroth này
I had mini đúng chứ
ở botswana class này
đúng không
và
còn nhiều bà đang nằm chứ
ờ ờ
Ừ ok
ô cửa sổ tay tôi đổi đây Thành à
Có ai đi
Cô gia sư của tôi đầu tiên cho Trả này
về trước đã nha à
ở khách sạn Châu Long các bạn này xin
lỗi nhỉ
Thế hả Dạo đấy Em đâu rồi đây đây có rất
nhiều bài đăng đúng chứ
em chưa hiểu lắm
đi mua đồ nào chúng ta
em gửi mua đồ trung gian đấy
anh giống người sắp chết bây giờ là cái
mua đồ trung gian đấy
à à
lấy sắp chết chứ ông đã này không làm
sai rồi ơi đang phải lấy sắp rách
hack many people là thông qua
à à
thế này
nhiều nhiều nhiều môn đúng chứ đúng
không
xe tải tông sẽ là có nhiều môn thông qua
như này Soi cái này đương nhiên phải sửa
lại đấy này bao nhiêu phải sửa lại Đấy
cái này sẽ phải ạ Ông cha cái
Em gái sao đây này à à à
là cái thằng gì
Hôm nay thằng cu check nó sẽ có nó sẽ
thông qua thằng này không ạ Để đến thằng
con này thì nó sẽ ra sắp rách ở đây này
không ạ Lan này sau đó đến bây giờ sắp
khách này
Đấy thế là xong tí thường em ạ
em gái tôi đang định bảo thì nó là nếu
mà giờ xử ông muốn lấy à
cho tất cả bài văn này nó + mạng thì ông
như tôi và báo ấy cũng sẽ chỉ cần à mát
ngay nó sẽ thử nhé
ở chỗ là mày ông đoạn này không làm được
thì mày không có thể inbox hỏi tôi mà à
đấy nhá bằng pass này à
A và mình sẽ có khái niệm là giọt thử
mình muốn lấy mỗi cái cột a
thế này
Sorry Turn
off telephone ý chứ không xem thử nhé
à à
i h u
Vì sao tại sao có pass đình
anh alo portsmouth xem
ở đó
thì tại sao lắp bắp ai hiểu ghi đè Còn
ai không được gợi ý mình sẽ ra Harry
Potter đi à
ở đây không thấy nó ra mạnh em sau đó
thì ông sẽ
à Ăn xét
ông đã có mạng danh sách toàn bộ tên các
tên các kiểu váy Đăng Nếu có không ạ ạ
phải là anh trên đâu
Ừ đúng em nhỉ Nhìn avatar chồng hơi 002
cũng á
hậu như đại không cần yêu
mít này rồi thì lấy ra thôi ok
em đi dạo này thì nó sai à
Ừ anh phải tin anh tự tin em chưa bao
giờ
em gái được cái đoạn này à
Ừ ok Nói chung à các bạn thử các bạn
Live về cơ bản thì vẫn mới với các bạn
Các bạn có thắc mắc gì có thể kiểu họ có
thể nhắn hỏi mình mình hỗ trợ không ạ
thì nói chung là mấy ông
mày có đoạn này vẫn còn mới mấy ông á
Mấy ông sữa xong mình mới có sẽ cậu sẽ
nhớ hơn lâu hơn và sẽ Cốt nó tối ưu hơn
- đoạn Vừa rồi chồng nó trong nó kiểu
bản thân mấy ông cũng thấy không chuyên
nghiệp mà không
Ừ nếu anh ấy có chứa nhiều cậu mình cũng
đang Cốt nó kiểu chỉ chạy được thôi mà
ông đang là cốt là chỉ chạy được thôi
chứ cũng không biết được là thực sự nó
chắc chắn là nó thấy nó có gì đó không
ổn nhìn Đọc cốt nó trong không Tối như
gì cả Không ạ Đấy và có thể truy vấn tao
bây rất nhiều đã lẽ là giống như tôi
hướng dẫn là mấy ông mà mày không phải
cày Level liebe hoặc cả hôm sau để cho
chỉ thêm cả
telescope vẫn cả clockwork nữa chứ không
mấy ông sẽ thấy ơi từ trước nay mình
truy vấn rất rất nhiều và là bài tốn rất
nhiều bộ nhớ và vân vân vân xong rồi
phạm chưa Tôi bảo mấy ông cài thêm cả
tiện ích điểm kiểu
pour homme này để mà hiển thị ra là cái
thời gian xử lý trang của mấy ông mà bao
lâu đấy Có khi mấy ông chạy 10 giây 10
cũng chấp nhận nhiều đấy giống hệt cái
hội mà tôi mới học g Nếu không nên như
thế ạ Nhưng không phải tối ưu hơn
I Pray Anh hôm nay mất tiền mà đừng cả
sinh viên em chơi dùng Day
ừ ừ
Anh nhìn cái khâu mục chăm bé có mất
niềm tin rồi à
ông ấy Tại sao FED ở đây này tôi có làm
mất niềm tin thật đấy ha
chứ
không phải đến ở trong controller nhá
nhỏ mèo đây sửa Dạo này đi
Anh chưa chơi đến ngày may mắn
nghe thấy ta chỉ cần ngắn gọn nó xoay 3
thôi
khi hòa lên kiểu Ẩm Thực ra về sau nên
chú thích hết bằng tiếng Anh cho chủ
nhiệm nó cũng được không ra mình đang
làm việc với việc thì lấy tiếng Việt
không sao nhưng mà về sau còn rất nhiều
từ chuyên ngành thực ra ông dịch ra khó
hiểu ấy cái ví dụ khi J5 này nó dịch
được ạ Đấy thì có nghĩa là nên để cái
tiếng Anh thì nó ổn hơn
Ừ cái này thật ra Nếu nó tốt thì ông có
thể Vứt cái này vào trong phương trình
hấp ơi nếu mà không dùng nhiều đúng
không ạ
thực phẩm chứa cái này cái chết nè
hình ảnh không thể tạo hình cái chết gì
mà kiểu trả về tự động trả về nó sẽ ổn
I Met a Tại sao trong controller là cái
con chắc của mấy ông Nếu phải truyền
thông tin này
ở sheet hay balo
haras
ông khoản mức câu chuyện như nào
I once it hay là nó có cái
em có kia mà
anh không hiểu đạo này của bạn ấy lắm
rồi rằng là kệ đây này nó có key chính
là cái ở giữa luôn rồi mà Tại sao ông
lại phải làm thêm loại này gian dài nghỉ
không hiểu à
Ừ cái này rõ là nó có khi đứng ở dỡ nhà
luôn rồi Nó lại đây có ghi và có bao lâu
ngày rồi tự nhau làm thêm loại làm gì đó
lâu á
tất cả cái này nữa
anh
không hiểu đoạn này làm giờ này đi
ở nhà thôi
bà đặt tên biến thì cũng sẽ kiểu như này
không phải thứ thứ cá nhân tôi Tôi không
thích nhưng mà rõ ra là theo chuẩn bây
giờ chẳng hiểu sao chuẩn của pp rồi nó
sẽ là kiểu như thế sẽ hiểu nó như này à
tôi không thích chúng ta thấy bổ não
ngắm thế đấy
Em mà về sau đó cậu về sau là mình là
mình dùng biết đâu về sau mình dùng
Facebook ra Swift mà người ta thấy bộ
này nó cứ cùng trái nghĩa gì
Ừ tôi càng nhân tôi không chết thôi chị
mày Ông ấy nên dùng class này như thế
này cũng được
ngã ba mặt xô cái sân
trò chơi gì máy đúng không Chỉ có mỗi
bên kia thôi Xin chào gì máy test thì có
nhiều test thì bao nhiêu ạ
em nói chào tốn thời gian theo cái đạo
thấy bố mới rồi chắc sáng tối thời gian
có nhiều đã hết buồn à
Ừ không sao Mình thấy vui được nó
làm nên bao giờ hôm nay ngồi kiểm tra là
mình không phải làm tương đối với nhà
ông Đừng Đập đi xây lại gì cả ngày ông
cứ tiếp tục phải làm thôi không được đi
xem lại cả tôi khuyên là khuyên thế mà ở
ông sẽ ông có thể là nói chung là rút
kinh nghiệm rất nhiều cái chữ Bây giờ để
ông ngồi đập đi xây lại thì ông bao giờ
mới xong được cái cái này không ạ
án hoàn chỉnh khi máu cơ thấy cậu đang
làm được chứ không thấy có vấn đề ngoại
pin xe lại ông ạ
Ừ cái cái bài toán ở đây Tôi đang dạy
xong mấy ông gần như là mô hình thác
nước với ông nhớ không ạ thác nước là
sao nghĩa là nó chỉ chảy từ trên xuống
dưới thôi nó không có chảy ngược lại cái
bọn nó mô hình thác nước một hình thang
nước
Ừ đấy Nó sẽ bao gồm là
để yêu cầu này thiết kế này phát triển
này test này rồi quay lại phát triển Nếu
mà test có vấn đề thì coi A a Không cái
này không phải phát triển mà nó là đi
pro là đầy đẩy lên đấy và bảo trì không
ạ Đây mô hình thác nước chứ không có
chuyện là gặp gỡ nhân test đương như còn
vấn đề thỉnh thoảng quay lại lấy tí
nhưng mà cái này thức a Chính xác cái
này là cái chỗ này thác nước nhưng mà
cái này cũng thì cái này có thể Cái này
còn gần cái này đi nhưng mà nó sẽ không
bao giờ kiểu dạng mà là phát triển nó
quay phát triển vọng phát triển của em
phát triển không Con chỉ chảy xuống thôi
Ừ cái này phù hợp cho việc là cái mục
Ông làm cái dự án có cái deadlines giống
như ngay bây giờ là có cái mép like thì
ông không nên quay lại cái bước trước
nho có vấn đề Ok mình giúp anh nghiện
mình làm những cái vằn mình vẫn phải
tiếp tục làm chứ không thể đội tiền lên
được cái này tao
vừa vừa có thể tốn kém thêm cả thời gian
và tốn kém hơn cả tiền bạc
thì nếu nếu mà những cái mô hình xăm hay
gì đó Mô hình này là khi mà ông đã có cả
một cục tiền xác định rồi và một cái đến
like gì rồi thì một cái deride cố định
rồi thì ông sẽ chỉ làm từ đầu đến cuối
ra xong rồi sản phẩm thôi A
và đương nhiên là nó thành công hết bạn
thất bại là do ngay từ lúc đầu ông thiết
kế nó mà hỏng hai a kiểu Nó gần như là
nói chung à Lúc đầu mà toàn thì đúng là
về sau toàn thật nhưng mà Thế nên là
thực cái này không hẳn khuyến khích ở
trong doanh nghiệp lắm nhưng mà thực tế
là khi mà có một cái their Eyes gì ông
rồi Ông không thể lắp định lại dân tộc
được không Vì có thời gian nhiều như thế
ở mô hình này vẫn áp dụng ở ở
nhiều nơi nha Em ăn chưa
nghe ngóng hiệu tăng
áp dụng
bao giờ mới xong đâu
nhóm nào để ông trời đã
biết thì tôi không chạy thì chạy ra tao
thề bồ cốt là để cho các bạn đi qua ra
tới bố thôi Còn bây giờ mẹ ông bị tốn
thời gian nhiều làm một bộ nhiều quá là
tốn được bạn này có dùng pin Jackson khá
ổn này driver à mà vừa là người lái xe
đúng không Rồi sao
hơn
các bạn này cốt để lấy cái cái này ra Ok
tôi hiểu
Ừ nhưng mà
I only
Vì sao phải ôn đi vào nhà nghỉ
được
Ừ ông vẫn vào đây mà sợ ông còn không
dùng của tôi là quần ông dùng tot.do
thuần nữa
ở cái đoạn này tôi thế Chai nghĩa gì
Ừ dạo này để sửa lại nó như này nhá nói
chuyện được hả quét nhà thôi
à à
A và múa lân ngay
Em hãy so it for light sẽ lấy được sẽ
lấy được là nó ra theo dạng buôn lần đấy
chưa xong còn kia pin thì đúng là khó
listen classf bằng hai 20 mưa không hiểu
loại nào ở
sư đoàn này không hiểu
A và xử lý các đoạn này như này nó rất
là khó hiểu vì sao mình không biết được
ván giặt dùng người trong mình hai con
số nào đó thì con số này của nó không
Tôi không biết là con số với đại diện
Cái gì con số này đại diện thì con số
đại diện này đại diện Cái gì chúng tôi
nghĩ là cách tốt nhất làm điều này thì
nó sẽ là cậu nên làm như này nó sẽ đô
legit ghét Nissin hai cái gì rõ ra sự
thế đúng không ạ là sự thế
Truyền doris lessing đây là lại
này sau đó thì mình sẽ tạo ra một cái
fibrate nên tạo ngay dưới này cái khái
niệm etro gì đây này
Private một cái file Phương Trần như này
này à
ngày đúng sẽ là
không hiểu classf cái gì lắm đại khái
ông sẽ get ơn giống hệt Vừa rồi ông làm
Return cái gì đó nhỉ
He has written cái này không ạ
này nên là một cái biến là một cái con
quần gì đó tối thôi Em vứt cái có sơn
Nói ngay đây này Nó quay vết đã con Sơn
ở đây giờ sự là là là kiểu nằm bờ
biết được không Mày làm gì mà sửa ngày
ông đặt như này thì ông phải dễ hiểu
đúng không Ông ấy lại dễ hiểu đúng không
phải tương tự và number kiểu sắp xếp ra
xử thế là sự đấy nhá Không biết ông 20
là cái gì
a nice xít em ạ ngay
à
nghe này thì về sau về sau
về sau ông làm đoạn này thì sẽ là cậu
đây chẳng để kiểu ngày nữa
à à a b sau ông muốn sửa Để ông sẽ chỉ
sửa con số ở đây thôi là có nhiều toàn
bộ đoạn dưới nó vẫn sẽ chạy không ạ ông
hiểu không sao này đi ông ạ
Anh hiểu hiểu đoạn hai
ở delhi quét ở đâu ở trên này nữa
Holy cow sleep
ở lâu gió
a fool nếu mà nó phun không ạ
a nice Garden
a bít tết
em hỏi làm đoạn này nói cho ông này lại
thi công chúng ta hết thế nào
anh vui rồi à
ạ Bây giờ tôi từng bảo tôi sẽ chữa nóng
lạnh tôi quên được
nhóm này nhé
một mình chán quá
Ừ dạo này xử lý quá diễn ra phức tạp ở
trong mối controller chỉ đơn giản là lưu
lại driver đúng ạ
khi cây kế Cái này là xong driver không
ạ tên nó store tất cả lưu lại driver
đúng ạ ông không nên xử lý những cái
khác
Anh ở trong một con trâu đơn này mà ông
lên Tống hẳn trong cái file khác thì xử
lý nó là phải trân là cái gì gió là tên
hạn một cái file tạm một cái thư mục lốp
Action xong rồi mình sẽ thử mình sẽ xử
lý những cái nó liên quan đến liên quan
đến cái thằng này ở trong đấy Cái bản
chất là xử lý những ngày thu dương gia
này không phải nằm trong controller tên
là Lưu lại Viber
Ừ ông hiểu không
Có ai còn quá rơm gà nữa
không nên dùng cái Hàn kiểu Cái này là
Doctor bai do thức là kiểu là câu FL
thuần mà mình sẽ khởi tạo đối tượng là
street đấy Sau đó thì ghét ID a kiểu
tròn đến nay đi các những thứ
thì mình nên làm quen với việc và đấy để
về sau mình bắt sự kiện là khi mà tạo
thêm mới một thằng đối tượng gì gì đó
thì nó sẽ chạy cái sự kiện gì giống như
ngay bây giờ này đưa rõ ràng là ông khi
ông lưu lại này thì nó sẽ chạy sự kiện
đấy nó sẽ chạy sự kiện cái đống này
không cần làm rõ chân nó nó chính là gửi
events khi mà ông mà ông lưu lại driver
nó sẽ chạy đồng hoa này không ạ Chứ
không phải ông Tống rồi không qua solo
như thế này
Anh hiểu chứ
Chị Hoa đã này nó bị dài dòng quá rồi
lắm Tôi dạy mày không cái huy tôn di dân
từ thế rồi mà không hồi sinh Không phải
show kiểu trả về kết quả này nhé
ế quá
bí quyết tất Thực ra nó tự động có rồi
tại ông chạy kiểu như này nữa thành ra
không được chứ chỉ cần gọi listen nó tự
động ATS coupe xuất rồi
Em chỉ cần đi Hay thôi
anh như thế phải không biết bếp vào Chạy
được cá này không
em ở nhà
anh
nói chưa chạy tuần này vừa ý
a song I
anh béo làm nó cứ rừng già của gì ra cái
này thì tao dùng não được này
kiểu gì nó sẽ lấy đúng không Rồi đấy
không thử nói
xong chị à Thì à
Ừ thì chữa cho có nhóm khác nữa không có
thời gian chữa nó khá kỳ công ở cái thế
thì hay như nào nhỉ
tôi bận thứ Ba lên thứ ba tôi sẽ chấm
tiếp và tôi sẽ chữa cho nhóm những nhóm
nào muốn những nhóm nào muốn tôi chữa
livestream và bìa nhóm này nhóm này kiểu
gì tội sẽ chữa like chim này hôm ấy sẽ
mít nhá sẽ gọi Mít để mà chữ like chim
nhá đầu tiên ông phải sửa toàn bộ vì do
của ông này cái thứ nhất này
em làm việc khái niệm lipid một ở đây
nữa phó tổng còn Demon Limit một làm gì
nữa vừa thôi à
khi nãy nói chung ông cứ sửa thế nào sửa
khóa học giữ nguyên như này để mà ông
ông sửa có khi không sao tôi vẫn đang
pin sẽ lại thôi đấy thì nói chung là tôi
hôm hôm sau nhóm này sẽ
nhóm này tôi sẽ cẩu Gọi Mít để mà chữa
còn nhóm nào 1 đăng ký nữa Thực ra à
thật là như tôi bảo ấy thì mấy ông đang
làm đồ án rồi thì thì mới ông sẽ chất
rắn ở nhiều lúc cần phải chữa đúng ạ thì
mày không được uống lại nhắn tin cho tôi
sau sau buổi livestream sau những buổi
livestream thì tôi vẫn ngồi im 1 lúc để
nó đợi mấy ông nhắn tin đấy thì mày Ông
cố vấn đề thì cứ nhắn tin cho tôi để mà
tôi sẽ chữa cho những nhóm với ông và
nhưng mà thôi buổi hôm sau buổi thứ ba
hôm sau rồi tôi sẽ livestream để chữa
mình nhóm nhóm nào cần chữa và muốn chữa
trực tiếp ở trên livestream thì tôi sẽ
chữa cho nhóm này tôi cứ cho bắt buộc đi
Ờ Ờ có gì nhé
làm cái đồ này ra mấy ông thích thì mày
Ông vẫn có thể nhưng bác riêng thôi
để xem tôi xếp nhóm được không hiểu
không thì ông cứ tự làm thôi ra rất
nhiều bạn vẫn đang vẫn đang làm và
em inbox tôi để nhờ tôi chữa và thuận
trí ở
chấm có mà Mấy ông không cần nhất thiết
phải bây giờ làm chưa về sau cái sao tôi
không có livestream dậy nữa nhưng mày
ông thích nhờ tôi chữa cho tôi vẫn sẵn
ai trợ giúp mà nếu không quên cái câu
châm ngôn của tôi ngoài có chuyên môn
cái câu gì cho câu à
Em không hiểu câu nói chung và câu câu
tôi cam kết nói nó khô cam kết đấy Kiểu
tôi sẽ nó bảo hành trọn đời mà đã từng
dạy mày Ông ngồi thì thôi Nói chung là
tôi
bảo hàng Thơm với ông miễn phí với ông
Cư có vấn đề gì cứ inbox thì tôi hỗ trợ
cái thoải mái vấn đề em ạ
ừ ừ tôi làm gì à
em gà bù gia do tính cách của tôi nói
thế Không quan tâm được tiền quan tâm
kiểu dạng là tôi thích thích giúp đỡ
người khác mà vui và tôi cũng kiểu nói
chung là tính Tôi là cậu cũng ca ngợi
thích được quan tâm thì hạn cũng đúng
thích được cư cho làn thích gây sự chú ý
đi là xử thế nghĩa là mấy ông chú ý đến
tôi tao vui em ạ Cho thấy đi
điều này khá này có mấy chị làm cơ bản
thêm thử Xóa
Em biết arivu không biết vậy có cái Hà
luôn
à Có sao mà không
hay nghỉ mini Sedan
À nhầm thấp tầm cao bán tải
ô ồ
anh đọc đọc
tôi chỉ cả hai
em hết kiby Blue
nhưng nhưng đoạn này có khuyên mà đặt
tên Hà mày nên khác khác một tí nhé bởi
vì hàm này tên sẽ rất dễ bị hiểu nhầm là
của thằng Y5 này có sẵn hiểu không Nếu
mà một người nào đó kiểu mới học cốt của
anh ấy đọc cốt của ông sẽ rất dễ hiểu
nhầm này cái này là hàng có sẵn của của
thằng i5 mà rõ ra hàng này ông tự tạo
riêng đều ngọn những cái hàm nên nên là
tôi nghĩa Nên đặt tên Kiểu như kiểu như
này chẳng hạn như này chắc bạn khác biệt
này còn ghét kiby hai cái gì đó thì
thằng i5 này nó có sẵn những cái ghét
key bài Blue hai cái gì đó thật rồi ông
đặt tên nó kiểu theo tôi nên đặt như này
à Ghét kiby bao lâu
à à invue đẳng tên nó dạy dòng một tí
nhưng mà không sao nó kiểu gì nó cũng sẽ
gợi ý ra cho ông rồi Ông gõ cái việc là
vì chính vì nó dài dòng nên thành ra là
kia sẽ người ta nhìn cái biết ngay ở
Chắc chắn là cái Hà mạnh khỏe hàng có
sẵn của nó là hàng mình tự biết ông ạ
anh nói thế Hỏi mấy ông Đặt tên tiếng
Việt đâu nha Bữa nào để chuyên nghiệp
Tiếng anh nhé Vẫn là nên là động từ đằng
trước mày rồi Ghét giá trị gì này bay
cái giá trị gì như thế này không ạ Cái
cụ thể hơn ở trong ngày chắc lại để
tránh được Lúc đầu tôi đọc cái này tôi
hiểu nhầm tưởng trong này chứ chứ không
phải là trong mày đúng không ạ Cái thì
kiểu inviewer nhẵn i love you đấy rất là
dài ra thì nó sẽ hiểu Dễ hiểu hơn không
ạ không chứ
Ừ dạo này thứ ra ông viết có thể ngắn
hơn được thật đấy
các bạn chắc đã hay chào về mạng mà ông
sẽ chỉ cần à
du lịch thi rồi cái mạng ấy thôi mà
fine thanks In Time
Store mu bạn này phải ra giống với nhà
nghỉ
anh bày rõ là có hàm để mà
lưu lại trong cái này nhanh rồi nghỉ
chưa hiểu rõ lắm
lấy được file em ấy nhỉ Sao toàn là hình
giọng ấy nhỉ Không thằng kia lấy được
phát cụ thể pass cơ
Ừ ông không muốn lưu lại Phát à
theo dõi đoạn này tôi nằm nhắn hơn mình
ở đấy Sao lại phải chưa phát rồi à
khi mà hết cho hạn chế làm tính năng xóa
nhé Xóa
xóa bây giờ Xóa ông sẽ ảnh hưởng rất
nhiều chỗ khác thì để em xóa Wifi này
Hôm trước thì nhờ tôi chị mấy ông ấy làm
được cái đoạn này rồi
ở nhà bạn này hơi sai này đã sợ chuyền
chuỗi vào trong như thế này
anh không nói không đi làm như này
thì tại sao ghét value gửi nhà nghỉ
Vì sao không chuyển thẳng là hãy làm như
thế này xong rồi đi Ti luôn
anh nghe chứ
anh hả
để tạo độ khó cho game thế Nói như này
mà
Em nói như này mà
đoạn này nó ngắn hơn mà
Em zô zô zô name
à Mà ông có 3 thằng thì ông
I Guess kiby Blue nhà ông cần lấy kia
đúng không Thì ông sẽ chỉ cần ông truyền
như này xong này
phải truyền tận hai cái này nha vẫn chưa
hiểu à
Ừ nhưng mà đây Ghét gì đây có hành này
nè
Ừ nếu mà ông không muốn ông mà ông muốn
tra hà thì ông ấy chị ông sẽ nhỏ ông sẽ
nhảy thằng
ông ông trỏ và thằng ngày để lấy cụ thể
thằng đấy thôi
Ơ cái thằng sao Vitek của tôi không trả
được nhưng mà không biết cốt nữa là
thằng Trung nó sẽ nhảy được đến thì ông
sẽ xem tất cả hàm của nó đọc qua tên của
nó là ông ghi hình dung được code nữa mà
gọi nhiều nhóm quá
Ừ là sao ạ
Ừ em đi xe ô tô có có
anh đi một tí rồi ngắm 13
Apple TP
phim hài
anh vẫn data-table
inbox luôn cái gì
biết vụ này nó bị cái kiểu ngay nó có
quýt có quýt hết đời mà
I was heading
này này không cần 12 ông sẽ cậu khi mà
inbox không có hết kinh rồi này which
had grown này sống sẽ truyền thẳng là
cột đấy bản chất cuộc đời tên là gì
nhưng lại luôn chứ không phải dâu 123
như này gửi cho ông
thì nó sẽ như lại
ở Pháp do là hay khi mà ông biết hết pin
pro rồi thì ông sẽ không cần stepro này
nữa sẽ bỏ đi cái
chị sẽ không cần em à
này rồi mày ở đây nói cho ông chỉ cần
with đúng mỗi viết hay Mango cũng xóa
được hai cái hai cái này ông sẽ làm đoạn
này đơn giản hơn chứ ông phải cứ 1234
như này nữa ông hiểu cho
năng thêm thử Xóa thật
Ừ vậy sao
a student đừng làm cái gì mà trò chuyện
với anh
ừ ừ
ABCD class
1tudien class
xem thêm
Ừ
cái bạn này là như thế nào nhỉ
có thêm sinh viên vào trong lớp đấy đúng
không
từ lúc mà tạo sinh viên phải thêm sinh
viên lớp đấy rồi đấy nhỉ
ở đời tôi không hiểu lắm
ở nhà ống Insert một mảnh anh Hai sinh
viên mà ông sẽ chọn à
khi chọn tầng sinh viên Bảo thêm từng
lớp từng học Anh nhớ để thấy lại sai ông
phải chọn rất nhiều sinh viên cùng một
lúc cậu chắc trách trách mặt thường là
cái đoạn đấy Nếu thế thì đoạn này của
ông làm Thể loại này sai rồi
xem mà em còn inbox ở đây mà
em không có inbox sinh viên đúng rồi
đoạn này bạn lại thêm sinh viên thủ công
từng bạn rồi
khi import vừa rồi lại có inbox là bên
này
import quan trọng nhất của ông đấy là
cái chứ đừng này thì ông ấy chưa là sẽ
làm đến ông ấy ngồi cập nhật thủ công
tay từng bạn một như này sau đó thêm
sinh viên vào lớp cũng thủ công từng bạn
một coi ai dùng phần mềm ngoài ức chế
lắm này
anh đúng không Ông hiểu rồi sẽ cậu như
này không Không được đâu Bây giờ ở nhà
khi mà ông import sinh viên là ông phải
có file CSV và ông sẽ nhập
số bài toán file CSV của ông sẽ hơi bị
khác rồi mới hồi tôi làm nó là cậu Nó là
kiểu dạng sự là có tên này đúng không ạ
Có lớp này thật sự thấy đâu nhá là sự
thế sử Long này xong rồi lớp là lớp lập
trình này anh à Nó quản trị này rồi anh
ấy
ở nhà không có lớn lập trình chả thế
đúng không ạ thì ông sẽ ông sẽ thứ nhất
là ông sẽ phải kiểm tra xem lớp đấy cho
tồn tại chưa Nếu mà Và nếu mà rất về
chưa tồn tại thì ông sẽ tạo mới thấy cái
tên này Đấy những cái khác để chấm được
này sau đó thì ông sẽ tạo bởi lớp thế
này xong rồi ông cho bạn Long này trong
lớp đấy và tiếp theo bạn này cũng sẽ thế
là tiếp theo bạn Này bạn này thì rõ lớp
này vừa được tạo rồi thì mình sẽ chỉ cần
lấy ID lắm đấy để chèn thêm vào bạn sinh
viên lại hội đúng ạ đấy Cái ông sẽ gần
như là
Ừ ông xã gần như là cậu thêm thêm mới
cậu vừa thêm mời cả lớp với thêm mới
sinh viên trong một cái file Excel thôi
cái file Excel này thường là bên
marketing hoặc cửa xe bến xe ấy sẽ gửi
cho ông cái file này kiểu Giả sử bên đấy
tuyển được sinh viên ở ngọn nó sẽ mấy
người đấy sẽ cập nhật vào trong phái Xem
này có hàng nghìn sinh viên này sinh
viên phải đăng ký ở lớp lập trình lớp gì
đó đấy sông sẽ tạo thậm chí thậm chí là
ông còn những thể phân lớp luôn ngay tại
thời điểm này là sử như tôi bảo là có
1.000 sinh viên thì không phải là 1.000
Sinh viên vào trong cùng một lớp do rồi
là nó có thể ở đây sẽ không phải lớp nữa
đây sẽ là sự đây nhanh lên lại nó sẽ là
cái bây giờ là ngành này như thế này và
ngành lập trình và ngành Quản trị còn
này lập trình thì lúc đấy ông sẽ kiểu
giả sự ông ông sẽ đến xem tôi thường làm
là tôi còn làn hơi bị nó chứ chuyên
nghiệp ông Tí tôi sẽ đến xem mà số lượng
sinh viên lập trình là bao nhiêu ở cho
anh xuống lượng Nói chung là kiểu nó sẽ
mãi mà tôi sẽ cho hết toàn bộ sinh viên
cùng mã lập trình vòng 1 vào chỗ cùng
một mạng đấy lớp Quản trị và cùng một
mạng và vân Thế nó sẽ theo mã của nó đấy
Xong rồi tôi sẽ bắt đầu chia ra Ví dụ là
trường cũ của tôi khi nước là tối đa một
lớp là 30 bạn nào ạ thì tôi sẽ có cơ
chạy erase like thế là nó sẽ cắt cái 30
cắt 30 các là 11 tôi sẽ có một cái mảng
sách đấy rồi tôi sẽ Insert vào trong một
lớp và tôi sẽ đặt lớp theo thứ tự tăng
dần thôi là lớp lập trình một nữa là 92
lớn lời trình ba ấy cứ thế
ở cái đoạn này nếu mà à
à mà ông không hiểu thì chắc là để hôm
sau tôi sẽ chữa xong với ông nhé Để tôi
nốt luôn nhé
ơ nhá Ok
để mô import I
Ừ từ định đúng chưa
Ừ không sao tôi đã trở lại này cho mày
ông nhé
Ừ thì thế nó mới thực sự là chuyên
nghiệp và gần như là có vài nhóm đang
làm về quản lý lớp học này chắc chắn sẽ
cần tham khảo về điều đấy ông ạ thì nó
mới thực sự là kiểu biết ông có cái bài
toán ở đây ông ngoài việc ông xử lý giải
quyết được bài toán của ông ấy thì các
bài toán đầu tiên của mấy ông lão làm
cần cái khó nhất là cái việc nhập liệu
vào vì người dùng người ta đang chưa
Dùng phần mềm của ông như người ta đã có
sẵn dữ liệu rồi ra có rất nhiều dữ liệu
rồi thì làm thế nào để người ta muốn
dùng phần mềm của ông bà làm sao cho mọi
người ta nhập vào nó dễ đúng
Lê Hồng không quan tâm và phần mềm ngon
như thế nào nhưng mà ngay từ lúc nhập và
người ta ức chế là không có dùng phần
mềm ôm rồi nó sẽ không mua phần mềm
không rồi nếu không hiểu cho
ông Lê là chắc chắn là cái phần nhập vào
mấy ông phải ổn trước đã trước khi có
tính năng sau thì cái tính năng đầu tiên
của mấy ông cần làm ngon đó thì nhập vào
nó dễ dùng hiểu chứ
Ừ ông đang nghe không Nãy giờ tôi nói
những cái đoạn rất nhiều lúc mấy cái cái
cái lúc mà tôi đang ngồi cho đoạn chuyên
ngành hơi khó là tôi không biết được là
mấy ông có theo kịp nghe không
để như thế nào
cho bỏ qua
Nghiệp vụ này cần phải xử lí nó nó phải
ổn cái phần lập trình mình gà với cơ bản
thì nó vẫn sẽ là nó vẫn chỉ có 3 quá
trình thực sự là thực ra vẫn chỉ bao quá
trình thôi đúng không nó nhập vào này xử
lý này và xuất ra như nào hiểu không
nhập vào phải ổn đúng không xử lý phải
ngon phía sau tôi chưa biết về ai nhưng
cái sau mấy ông mà ốp thêm rất nhiều
công nghệ các thứ thứ nữa thì con xịn
không ạ đây sau đó thì khi xuất ra phải
là cái khác cái nhập vào họ khỏi xuất ba
giống hệt cái nhập vào thì dùng word ra
dùng ấy treo ngay không ạ Đấy thì
anh nói chung là ông làm 3 giai đoạn đấy
ở đâu phải ổn nhưng mà giai đoạn đầu
tiên cái ấn tượng đầu tiên người ta là
cái nhập vào đã đã phải ngon đã ẩm thực
sự người ta chưa Người ta đã nhập vào gì
để người ta biết được là ông xuất ra
ngon như nào đâu đúng ạ Nó không có tâm
được đấy
anh không ạ Nếu không phải ăn điểm cái
đầu tiên này còn nhập vào đã hôm đầy mồm
thế hôm đầy mô mấy ông phải thể hiện
được rõ cho tôi nhá ốm không bảo vệ đoàn
đấy
có báo trước là sẽ có người người có cả
người bên khác có thử thứ có đi nhá Đấy
em nghe nói chung là hôm để mô mấy ông
phải
demo được rất tốt về cái vụ nhập vào để
nó tạo ấn tượng ban đầu luôn và xử đấy
chính là khách hàng của mấy ông đi nếu
bạn phần mềm đi không ạ thì cái việc giờ
cậu ngay từ để mua lúc đầu nếu không
phải có ấn tượng không phải quan tâm mà
Mấy ông nhảy sang bên thống kê luôn đâu
Mấy ông nhiều lúc đầy mô nhảy sang thống
kê luôn là mấy ông làm sai rồi không
phải có tâm việc là lúc nhập vào nó phải
ổn đã xong rồi đấy ông ấy bắt đầu để mô
xanh là bọn em xử lý ngào để mà hiền chị
ra cái phần thống kê hiển thị ra cái cái
xuất ra nó như nào
thế nào của một cái phần mềm ý thực ra
là các bạn Thể tra trên mạng nó rất
nhiều Tôi thì ra tổn thường nên tham
khảo trên mạng thôi tôi không hẳn có một
cái thước đo chính xác của nó nhiều
người thì đo bằng thời gian các bạn là
đã cốt trong vòng bao lâu và các bạn
tượng quy ước là giọt sự là một tiếng
các bạn cốt giờ sử các bạn lấy Có thể
bây giờ các bạn đang nghiệp dư Lấy rẻ là
là 10.000 20.000 nhãn Giả sử gia xử thế
thường thế hơi dài quá nhưng mà Mấy ông
Nam thực tập mà đây là sự thế nha bạn
cốt 100 giờ rồi cho cái phần mềm chị 200
giờ rồi thì 200 nhân với 10.000
Ừ vậy thôi sẽ ra số tiền bán phần mềm
đấy nhưng mà Nếu thế thì nó sẽ hơi bị
nhiệm vụ một tí à hơi bị à không phải
nghĩa vụ dùng từ như nào nhỉ Nó bị công
nghiệp gì con nếu mà Mấy ông muốn bán
theo kiểu là bởi vì nó có giá trị thương
mại theo kiểu giá trị được nó có thể ra
nó có rất nhiều giá trị nữa Chẳng ạ thì
ông có thể chơi theo là kiểu là nó
cho nó
giải quyết được bài toán giảm được cái
sẽ giảm được cái gì nhỉ
Thời gian công việc cũng như cũng như là
nếu mà không có phần mềm đấy người ta
phải dùng cái tương tự như thế nào hoặc
là người ta phải thuê bao nhiêu người
giả sử Giả sử nhé Giả sử tôi ngồi cho
tôi làm phần bến nhà chưa Nếu mà tôi
tính ra không phải theo rò mà theo kiểu
là bài toán về giá trị nữa bởi phần mềm
lấy hộ nó có thể hỗ trợ được tận nó có
thể quản lý được Hằng nhìn chục nghìn
sinh viên cùng với độ chẳng hạn đấy kết
hợp với việc là Ý là nếu mà có lượng
người liệu sinh viên như thế thì phải
cần bao nhiêu người nếu mà không dùng
phần mềm tôi phải thuê bao nhiêu giáo vụ
để mà làm việc đấy và sẽ phải dùng phần
mềm nha Vân sẽ sẽ tốn bao nhiêu giờ để
mà xử lý xong một cái công việc ạ Cho
ông sẽ tính cộng và những điều đấy thì
ông sẽ ra được con số ông sẽ quy ước là
sự là 1.000 sinh viên thì sẽ là bao tiền
sẽ nói chung là sẽ nhân về theo cả là
vì số lượng nghiệp vụ cái này thì đúng
là mấy ông Nếu mà chuyện với bệnh kinh
doanh mình không sẽ giỏi phân tích cái
này hơn để mà còn như mấy ông cũng đi đi
đấu giá dùng từ đầu ra đúng bạn Nga đấy
Kiểu mấy ông sẽ nông nếu không sẽ bảo Và
nếu bây giờ sự không có phần mềm của tôi
kiểu bên mình phải thuê như này sôi đổ
hãy mất bao nhiêu giờ chỉ ngồi nhập điểm
hay nhập liệu con hư thứ với sao xong
rồi thống kê cũng bằng cái sao rất khó
thấy tối bao nhiêu rồi ngại thì cái số
tiền đấy số tiền lương của trà cho luôn
đấy người Vân tốn bao nhiêu đấy và giải
pháp ở đây đó là phần mềm này còn có đem
lại giá trị trong vòng ít nhất là 10 năm
nữa cam kết thì có vân chẳng hạn thì nó
dạy ra được số tiền thôi
từ nhỏ
trăm trong 10 năm cũng
Ừ cái đấy một kiểu khác Nói chung nó rất
nhiều kiểu tính rất nhiều kiểu máy tính
trường tôi là người cô đơn hả ấy
ăn theo học phí của sinh viên à Thế
không chơi nữa
mà mình chém gió nãy giờ Tiếng rưỡi rồi
cái kia
Ê mày cho tao vẫn cơ bản toàn bộ cơ bản
này nhưng mà chắc là nó mày cha ở hôm
sau tôi chỉ cho để mà nó có những cái
bài toán hơn hôm nay hình giờ chưa sang
mấy cái bài toán nghiệp vụ
cho nó trẻ mấy cái cẩu thêm và xóa mấy
cái bảng các bạn thôi
định hết tất cả nó mày nhưng vẻ hơi
nhiều xem mà có khi mà khi là
Ừ chắc là để hôm sau chưa tiếp các bạn
hôm nay rút kinh nghiệm bổ sung dần Để
hôm sau tôi sẽ chữa tiếp vậy
Ừ đúng rồi Nhưng mà nếu thế hôm sau chửa
tiếp thứ ba chữ tiếp thì bao giờ mới để
mua mấy ông kịp nghỉ thứ ba Chắc là nếu
không thứ ba tới chữa nhanh người ta vẫn
sẽ livestream hôm thứ ba tôi Lysine muộn
đi tôi chấp nhận livestream muộn để mà
tôi tôi
dạy ít nhất là cái nhóm tám vừa nãy Chào
bạn
về giá cả cái Ngó mà nhóm đây cái để mua
Inbox hay nữa
à Hôm nay thứ gà cũng là chị hơi muộn
vào thực ra Thứ Bảy ra muốn à cho mấy
ông nhà tạm nghỉ ngơi đã
chủ đề cứu tạm mới đến nhóm 14 nhá Hôm
sau nhóm 16 các thử sau nhé
là tôi vẫn sẽ đập đi sẽ lại của ông thôi
Ừ ông ông cứ tạm sao ông cứ tạm làm tiếp
những cái rồi Ừ ông ông hiểu rồi giờ xử
ông hiểu rồi hoặc không làm cái khác đi
Để hôm sau tôi để mua tôi làm lại chứ à
mà Thậm chí ở thời cá hôm sau tôi chữa
thì ông cũng không cần phải đập đi làm
lại cậu cho phong cách của tôi chữa đâu
chứ không sai hẳn thôi còn ông làm rồi
thì nó vẫn chạy được Thì ông nên giữ
nguyên ông đừng có nên động Thảo đóng
ngoặc
em không hiểu cho không không nên động
vào những cái mà đang chạy rồi mà đúng
không
Chợ Tốt có thể xấu cái thứ thôi kệ Izumi
nghiệm cho cho đi làm ngồi làm pass
forex nữa Cái này sẽ phố rách để mà mày
ông có cái để mà đi đi phỏng vấn với ông
khoe nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà Ờ cũng đừng cho người ta xem
cốt thì cả với người ta xem cốc xong
nhìn cốc kiểu gì cũng xấu chả trứng
nghiệp thì cả Không ạ Thì ông nên tạo
một cái tôi khuyên mày Ông vẫn lên có
kiểu làm xong cái này vẫn nên có một cặp
vô trách nữa một cái phố check theo và
đam mê của ông lúc đấy thì cốt xịn trong
đấy cuốn rất có tâm nhưng lấy Vân rồi
ông khoe cái cái best forex đấy thì nó
hay hơn đấy
Ừ ông nhậu không thể có tận 3 đồ ăn khoe
đoán một em làm pate khuẩn đón hay làm
Lava em bắt đầu tiên được lao đoàn 3m
ứng dụng mà Cái đấy để em làm thử Em đam
mê đấy có ba cái đồ án tổng thầu mà khoe
rồi đúng không ạ đấy Ờ chư ông ông khoe
cái đùa này thì nó vẫn nhằm nhờ kiểu gì
nó cũng em nhờ thì ông mới bắt đầu học
lại ông mà ông đừng có đừng có kiểu cầu
toàn quá cầu toàn khóa thì ông hiện chỉ
quanh quẩn đi quanh còn lại tốn quá
nhiều thời gian trong một cái phụ trách
Ừ thôi bản thân tôi thường hay thế nhưng
mà mình vẫn vẫn phải kìm lại cái rồi đấy
mình người nào mà kìm lại được bản thân
mình
Ừ thì nó sẽ khẩu sẽ là một người có ý
chí nghị lực cao không ạ Chứ một người
mà kiểu
anh cũng hiểu nghe người ta nói cái là
sửa thì nó hơi bị ba phải
Em đừng nghĩ ở đấy cầu toàn như câu toàn
lắm Chị ở tiến lên nhé cái à rút kinh
nghiệm và làm làm cái khác xịn hơn chứ
không phải là của cầu toàn đâm đi đâm
lại và một cái forex với sống sẽ khoe
rồi có một cái cô chắc thôi Cho dù nó
ngon như là nó cũng chỉ một cái thôi ông
ạ
Anh hiểu chứ
thế kiểu gì tôi nghĩ là kể cả mấy ông có
thể nghe không hiểu thì về sau dần dần
hiệu hoặc ạ nghe lời cho thấm thì sẽ dần
dần thấm không ạ nhà tội nói đi nói lại
mấy cái vụ đấy nha bây giờ là
có một ngày 16 rồi 37 thử đúng không
Rồi Sang tháng là mình sẽ
khi liên tục kiểm tra bảo vệ khu vực các
số thứ 02 đến tháng 9 tra là thưởng tầm
Mỹ Tâm Hà 27 27 tháng 8 là mình sẽ gần
như bảo vệ chính thức cho hỏi đi giờ thế
ngoan rồi à
ba tháng 9 là mình rẽ Giả sử bảo vệ một
buổi không hết thì sang tháng 9 bảo vệ
buổi tiếp theo cho những nhóm sau đầu
nhọn rồi à
tháng 9 là mấy ông cũng có thể dân dân
lại kéo Lũ lượt đi thực tập rồi gói
Ừ ngoan 7 tháng 10 tôi cũng bắt đầu chốt
là là đi dạy thì chả không ngờ rằng
livestream với ông nữa Gần như ở cố hoàn
thành hết xong trong tháng 9 ta ổn không
ạ
thế nhỉ Cứ tạm thế đã rồi tính tiếp
ở ngoài chắc chỉ thôi chào bé ông nhé